is here
sunday night edition
what the [ __ ] has happened lisa yeah i
don't know i have no idea what's about
nothing's gonna happen you're just gonna
sit there like a [ __ ] momo it's great
to be back
i'm sorry about missing last wednesday i
was on my way to new york city so we
just uh ran out of time
so we figured we'd catch up with you
wake up to some [ __ ] great podcasting
on a monday morning
start your day off on the right [ __ ]
foot oh school you know what i'm saying
just me and the flying jew
new york city was [ __ ] great i mean
the last 10 days
have been hard for people asking we shot
a special in vegas last week
i basically came home
did a few workouts had some auditions
packed and went right back to new york
uh the special it you know leigh's
putting it together now we gotta still
shoot a wrap around so it's gonna be a
while so i know that you guys i'm uh
very proud of the thoughts and the
support and the questions but
special won't be around till maybe
december maybe end of november but we'll
keep you posted here but new york city
was just [ __ ] sensational you see you
texted me that's why i know it's good is
when you text me and text me pictures of
all the channels dragging in oh right uh
so jealous
is that where you started
started uh they picked me up at kennedy
went to the hotel checked in which is
the first time i stayed at this home
with sweets
and it was just phenomenal [ __ ] i'm
close to rudy's i'm close to the cuban
joint which delivered to my hotel room
so here's look here's the question i had
if if you went to 100 places 99 of them
you would stay next door to the club
this is the only place that you go that
you take a trip to go
well the problem is that if i stay in
new york city i won't come over to see
my family uh i'm that lazy i'm that
[ __ ] lazy so what i do is i
compromise
i go back on wednesday and thursday is
my new york day i go to opening anthony
after an open anthony i run some errands
what i did instead of opium anthony was
this week i was going to go to
jiu jitsu but instead i took the a train
uptown i walked around 148th street i
didn't go i was gonna go to 86th street
and go see my uh grammar school and
stuff yeah but i really wanted to walk
around 148th street
i walked down the hill i looked at
riverside drive i walked up the hill
and then i took a cab up to [ __ ]
george washington bridge and i took the
bus over and then my buddy picked me up
and went to eat cuban food i took a
couple ferries yeah i saw that which was
[ __ ] dynamite you know right from
edgewater or weehawken i took the ones
from edgewater right in took them right
back they're nice i took that before i i
think i went to go visit nyu or
something we stayed in uh right across
like wherever that ferry drops you off
like there's a hotel like right there
right there and it's uh
that's one thing i definitely miss about
the east coast is i mean
it wasn't hard for you to get back into
new york i can't imagine this you could
get back from new york every 15 [ __ ]
minutes oh could you take that ferry
back in like three no no no no no i
think during the week it's one on the
weekend it's one
and during the week the last one is 12
10 back still but it was dynamite just
getting on there at night listen anybody
who knows new york city or boston or
that part of the country
september may and april
are just beautiful times of the year to
be on the east coast for me
this was every time i go home i've
always told people that
if you're having a problem in your life
you're having doubts you're having
insecurities maybe you have marital
problems do yourself a favor
some people instead of hanging out put
some dough together
and go back to where you're from i don't
care if it's toledo ohio i don't care if
it's
quincy mass i don't care if it's [ __ ]
somewhere in iowa or mankato minneapolis
minnesota i'm sorry of boise idaho when
you go home
after being gone after being an adult
it really does something to you
especially if
you tap into that energy
there's an energy you tap into when you
go back that you go oh i used to go to
that school wow that's not a shoe store
no more
and if you get out of your car and park
and just walk up and down
it gives you this empowerment like you
get that this empowerment that you know
what i'm still walking these steps
like i walked the steps i went to
grammar school like i went to the
cemetery and i put some flowers
and even being there and turning around
and looking around i just looked at the
playground
and turned around and
i couldn't hear it in my hearing i don't
know if i don't want people to think i'm
crazy
but in my head i could hear kids in the
playground like when i used to play in
that playground and stuff like that so
you realize how [ __ ] lucky you are
whether
you're sick there's something wrong with
you you're jobless
that you're still walking these streets
like it was just so
surreal for me it always is did it upset
you that there were changes uh because i
went back to my hometown for like the
real first time
god
probably six or seven years if if not
more
and it was weird for me like they
changed so much of it i barely
recognized it and i had that feeling
like yeah it was cool to see it but then
part of it was like oh they changed
everything like they painted the house i
grew up in a different color and it was
just it was weird listen with me
change is evolution you're going to go
back and things are going to change
people are going to get old people going
to die the sun's going to take over the
pizza place it's not as good as it was
whatever the [ __ ]
it is but there's always those things
there's always those constants for us
in north bergen we lost ashwas deli
which was my constance
that's the second thing i did was go to
hashways and get the news on the town
and the gossip and you bump into cops
and stupidity but it was home
it was really home and my friend billy
horenda who does like sports up in
sacramento
i was speaking to him excuse me and he
was telling me how he was lost when he
went back without hash ways being there
because that was his staple you know
nick died the pizza place that's it but
then again i'm 50. we're older and this
is expectant you know
i made the best of it for me
when i go home i gotta tell you
it's seen
a certain handful of friends right and
this time i [ __ ] up i didn't see
carmine i didn't see mr baroon i just oh
no yeah i didn't have a car to go down
my car mine so tomorrow i'm going to get
an earlobe
he's he's you to me oh that's okay
torments me with this [ __ ] so it's like
uh
but i've seen lubes i've seen timmy
holloway who gave me statues of jimmy uh
jimmy page and
you know timmy had some problems and he
cleaned up
and he looks [ __ ] like a like a like
a model we giggled their asses off last
night he drove me in and out of the city
i saw the freehold of an area went out
to dinner with rudy's i saw james
i saw my girl lisa messina i saw james's
daughter i saw the hand group of people
i saw grandma oh she's still
she's hanging around 97. but she thinks
he's 103.
i saw his daughter do you think she's
103. yes because i'm 103 and george is
arguing with a grandma you can't be 103.
you were born and whatever
but just seeing all that that even
grandma when grandma was 60 i was there
when she was 60
and now she's [ __ ] 90 and she's still
tormenting me you guys you smell like
eek eek
she used to call eek reefer you know
that's so funny
opie and anthony was great you know just
seeing jim and uh pete [ __ ] is crazy
davidson he's [ __ ] nuts i love him
he's [ __ ] nuts
uh
well did uh veneria ask you to be his
driver
no i asked him i said what do i fill on
the application and he just started
laughing you know they talk about that
political town how political it is and
they're robbing
but you know what the town is clean
they got anti-fucking
i went on friday night to the park and i
saw these different type of cops and my
friend just explained to me that their
task force on fridays and saturdays to
you know get the uh curfews and stuff
like that you know 11 o'clock i mean
do i believe in a curfew for kids
if i had a curfew may be able to grow up
to be a different person so
who the [ __ ] knows but it was just great
to go home the shows were great i went
to the stand the first show i did well
the second show i ate dick how was the
food i heard the foods i didn't eat i
really no i didn't eat i had this drunk
guy giving me a [ __ ] ear beating
the whole night i couldn't eat because
if i got food and he sat there and gave
me an air beat and i just hit myself in
the head with the [ __ ] arugula
sandwich whatever the [ __ ] i was gonna
eat
the stand was great gotham was
sensational i gotta tell you that's a
great comedy club
the people the organization the staff
there
is sensational yeah sensational what
makes a good staff at a comedy club
like what as a comic what do you look
for
they're efficient
they're quiet i didn't even know they
were there
everybody asks you if you want something
can i help you is this something i could
get you that always blows my mind at
comedy clubs when you can hear like the
wait staff aren't quiet and try i was a
waiter it's a hard job and you're gonna
make some noise
but like some waiters just like full
comfortable like conversation level
start asking people what they want
during a set and i'm like
it's just you do realize this is a
comedy club right it's like it's not tga
fridays where you last worked it's nah
there's people hey listen i did the 11
45 show yes they must have been tired so
it's gonna be a [ __ ] late show yeah
you know what it went smooth
my set the first night was a little
choppy but second night i really had it
down and that's all that mattered to me
i always want to perform strong in new
york you know
is it because you you you're having
you're like selling pretty well around
the country but like for the past few
times you've gone to gotham you've sold
out pretty is it is it cool is it still
called you because you yeah and that was
like a week earlier
listen this shit's not supposed to be
happening
and it's happening and uh
for a guy like me i'm like a kid in a
candy store
it's pressure but at the same time i
[ __ ] love it i love living in like
this and i love the people who come out
and the people i talk to i met so many
cool people the black guy who called you
the threat oh my god if you didn't come
back to new york with me next time he's
gonna shoot you uh he's gonna come what
do you say to me he's gonna come down
and roll up on he's like he's like
something like real talk man yeah it's
been three years where the [ __ ] are you
and i was just sitting at home i didn't
have 10 i didn't have a chance to tell
you i think in the star oh i know you i
like this freaking god i was just
sitting there high you're like and that
you were calling me like after the third
black guy came up to me and looking for
you i go that's it i've had it with
these [ __ ] black people looking for
lee they don't like me they're looking
for a jew what the [ __ ] is wrong with
these black people i don't know but i
love it this guy had dreads he was solid
he came right up to me gave me a hug
another guy the guy that called you
looked like an uh that guy from that
group i can't remember now i'm sorry he
was dynamite i thought maybe it was
new york city's got some dynamite remain
carcione was dead
new york city has done we have a great
network in new york city when the people
come to the shows in new york city they
shake my hand they look in my eyes
they hug me real [ __ ] hard
they appreciate it which makes me
appreciate them
i never had this before i can't even get
on i can't even get a [ __ ] special on
netflix i can't do nothing but these
people are coming to the show so what
the [ __ ] do you think i feel like
what the [ __ ] do you think i got to work
harder now
than i've ever worked why do you think
i'm here because i want to thank those
people i want to thank everybody who
supports us
we got a great thing we have our own
network of people that help each other
look at the [ __ ] picture oh yeah okay
let me zoom in on this because this is
great this is just amazing this is the
[ __ ] that listen man i get [ __ ] on
twitter and
but guys
for the 90 percent
what we have going on on twitter and
facebook amongst ourselves
it's [ __ ] i'm telling you i i want to
cry sometimes this picture right here by
levpoli
yakov.com
this is one of the greatest p and he
drew fidel
perfectly and super bad and [ __ ]
dimmy he must have looked at old videos
yes so i gotta respect this guy it's lee
killing the [ __ ] devil we're going to
put this in a poster with his permission
we're going to get a hold of him
if he's listening i want him to contact
us this is just mind-boggling
some other guy great guy and his sexy
beautiful girlfriend came to the shows
they gave me an album they gave me
blizzard of oz the first album they came
to [ __ ] two or three shows what about
the blizzard twins or no the whitney
with the wizard the dragon twins dragon
twins that was hysterical dragon
brothers they came with a boat a kung fu
looking [ __ ] ready to tackle
people
like i said man i'm here tonight because
i just couldn't wait till monday with a
guest
we love you with all our [ __ ] hearts
and this is not about monetary this is
not about [ __ ] it's not and that's this
is about i want to come i'm with my
family i was just laying on the floor
with mercy
watching [ __ ] uh
humpty dumpty on halloween or some [ __ ]
and i i just i i learned listen man i
wouldn't want a life
where i didn't learn things about life
but most importantly i didn't want
i can't imagine not learning things
about myself
every week i like looking back on sunday
and going wow that was a great week
what did i learn about myself this week
you know and this week for me i learned
that and that's why i don't harp on it
man god makes his choices karma makes
their choices
but you have one thing at the end of the
day
and this is i've always judged myself by
this and this is your friends
the people that are around you uh
the guys that came from timmy holloway
the lubes to how's lubes oh
listen i wasn't in the hotel
i gotta admit something to you guys all
right i get off the [ __ ] plane they
take me to the hotel
i'm not at the hotel ten minutes and the
phone rings upstairs
i never ever ever hans answer the hotel
phone the hotel phone ring oh [ __ ]
that's old school
and i didn't answer and right after that
the phone rang and it was loose and he
goes where are you
i got him in my hotel room i go what
time do you want to hook up he goes
i'm already downstairs
i go park the car i'll come down and get
you i went down he had a tub of chicken
cutlets parmesan and a bake and a bowl
of baked ziti that's the way to greet me
i sat right in front of them i hugged
them we went up to my room i ate the
ziti in front of them and uh then he
goes i forgot this chocolate cake my mom
make chocolate cake for you you know and
i go tell your mom thank you let's call
her
and as i'm doing all this i'm realizing
i've been going to this kid's house to
eat since
1970 [ __ ] nine
how old were you
first time i walked in his house i was
15 years old i walked in this house a
month before my mom died
for a party we all
played hooky do you remember what it
looked like
huh do you remember what the house
looked like oh yeah i'm fascinated by
that stuff like no lives there the house
looks like it smells a certain way he
still lives there he lives in the middle
room at that time he shared a room with
his older brother with the medium
brother
they had a uh
they had a basement that was all made
for weights all homemade lat machines
all this [ __ ] and i remember that he had
a little party there
and i had uh
stolen some coke
from some coke that was downstairs in my
basement my mother was holding on to
some people
i took a little bit of it and i had it
hidden and i uh that day i took it to
the park i took it with me to school
and i took it to the party and i pulled
him aside maybe you want to do some coke
and he's like wait you get it and we
we got a peppermint schnapps and vodka
and we made drinks and we
sat down and i did a couple lines of
coke with them and i threw the rest away
and it was
it was our bond it's been our bond
forever
cool i've turned this way in his book it
was just something when you it's like
timmy holloway me and timmy holloway did
that jewelry store
you know that's a bond that'll last
forever we got away with it
you know we both had something there's
something about a street bond
when you do something there's something
about a bond of human beings
but there's different bonds it's like
twins have a special bond
you know when i see timmy
and everything else
is forget like i forget everything else
i just see that kid that we were both 16
in the same boat looking for a [ __ ]
direction
and here we are 30 years later who the
[ __ ] are we getting we're still looking
for a direction
how long has lube has been bringing you
chicken cutlet and pasta to hotel rooms
like you you've told me that he's
[ __ ] he did that like even when you
were like coming gonna visit when i i
the bigger the man the bigger the
mistake and the bigger the story you
know whatever the [ __ ] you want to talk
i could look you in the eye and tell you
as a man that if it wasn't for
jimmy lubes
roger and timmy
ask elise
and george kaladinsky i would not be
here today
i know that for a fact because
lubes has been feeding me and giving me
20s and 10s
since i was uh
maybe 17. you know 16 was the first time
i went to his house but when i started
getting into trouble and needed rides
and whatever he's been there for me for
all those rides you know
i was telling uh
mike ascalis who were sitting there
talking and i said
i go there was a time when i used to
take i used to sleep in your backyard on
the on the uh
you know the [ __ ] things where you
take a suntan and you you lay down you
know like lawn chairs
in the winter with a jacket on with a
hooded sweatshirt
and then i would wait till the morning
until everybody left the school on knock
on the door and janine would give me
breakfast
and i'd sneak in and take showers in the
[ __ ] basement and she'd give me a
clean shirt from her father's to wear
and i would have to avoid her father all
day because then he would say how did
you get one of my shirts
you have no [ __ ] idea so i know i
know you and your stepfather didn't run
on the best terms right and i know you
chose to go with the benders because it
would have
upturned your life but when you're
sitting there homeless
none of you were like okay i'll go live
with him i'd be
i wouldn't like it but it wasn't there's
no way i was going to give in to a guy
that i was at real i had war with oh
there was no way and that night
i don't know i was just i could i could
have gone to one
reason i didn't really want to admit
that i lose
i had people that i could have gone to
you know and uh but i look at this kid
loops that
in 1993 when i was starting comedy
he was bringing me
you know little things i remember one
time i came i went back on the road i
was in 98
you know i would stay on people's floors
and go into the new york comedy club and
do spots and i remember one night i was
waiting for a bus and he pulled up
i can't lie he had like maybe 18 miles
in my pocket i was still doing blow he
pulled up he's like what's up nothing
i'm going to the city goes get him i'll
give you a ride he goes i got something
bringing the back some valiums let's do
a bump
you know do you need money to get home i
mean this week when i was home he he's
the one that drove me to the cemetery
i had a he wanted to pick me up and
drive me to both gigs both nights
and i told him no you know i'll go with
my friends you know whatever
i mean it's just amazing to still have
that support system
i don't ever want people to think that i
was just out there
one thing that kept me alive was the
support system i had but because i had
that support system
i also want then wanted to make them
proud
which has always been very important in
my world
is making anybody who did something for
me anybody who said like if i come to
you and i go dog i'm in a bind
and you're like what do you need i go i
got to get to san diego by 10 o'clock
and you're like you know what come on
you got weed let's go and also on the
way down i go to hand you 50 bucks for
gas you're like don't worry about it
i can't never forget that and then you
drive me home let's say you're not even
a comedian
let's say you're just a lawyer and you
do this for me how do you think i feel
you just gave me a ride down there to do
my dream and you enjoyed it and you had
a good time and you came back i'll never
forget those people that gave me rides
[ __ ] the fulato last week you know why
you know what the most special thing
about shooting that special was
tell me that the guy
the least likely we all have
something you want to do with your life
and then you go to the people that are
closest to you and you tell them you go
you know what
i'm thinking of becoming a professional
dick sucker you know i love m m's
you know whatever the [ __ ] you want to
become
and let's say you go to four of your
good friends
two of them are gonna tell you you're a
[ __ ] loser and two of them are gonna
support you
you know two of them aren't gonna say
you're a loser i don't want you to put
it like that but two of them are just
gonna
raise the other possibilities you know
you have a family
what are you gonna do if you fail and
then you have two friends let's say out
of those two friends you have one friend
that uh is very
um he's had [ __ ] going on in his life
but the other friend is a childhood
friend who's a mess
what if this guy that was a mess
the least person in your life drove you
to gigs
what if that guy gave you a book once on
stand-up comedy what if
that was philadel's cousin
in 1993 when i went back to new york and
i didn't know what i was doing in my
life at 32 years old guys i had no idea
what the [ __ ] i was gonna do with my
life i had been on stage a couple times
i was like that girl that fat shamed i
was telling people it was a comic that
was no [ __ ] comic i was getting on
stage once a [ __ ] month
i told him my dream and for some reason
he would push me every day you go to the
city tonight and do comedy let's go i'll
give you a ride i'm like oh [ __ ] now i'm
in a bunch yeah now i'm gonna [ __ ] why
do you think i pushed you with the jiu
jitsu anything i got that from from him
yeah because i get it i get when
sometimes you need that person to say
come on and now you're in a spot why'd i
[ __ ] even tell this [ __ ] i
did i did i could do comedy four nights
especially like when i because i when
i'm like dreading jujitsu
if i don't have an ex if someone's
offering you a ride it's like you can't
even say oh i ran out of gas my car
broke down
like that
oh okay let me ask you this when you
first started comedy did you enjoy it
yes and no
when did you start like when did you
stop dreading it i
i you know what i didn't like about it
then i sucked yeah
nobody likes to suck no even if it's uh
jumping jacks nobody likes to suck on
anything
but anybody who has a brain will go home
and go you know what
they'll go on youtube in today's society
i don't know maybe 20 years ago when i
was growing up i couldn't do that but
they go on youtube and they see somebody
who is doing it and they'll say you know
what if he could do it i could do it
that's the mentality if he could do it i
could do it
well i'm going to try till i do it and
maybe if i don't [ __ ] get it at least
i [ __ ] try
right but that was why fulato was so
special that he was there
because it was like a representative of
his family like it was in other words
rhaegar was there only fellata was
representing them this is the guy that
got me into comedy this is why it was so
special for me
and
did you like have to ask philadelphia
i'm asking thinking i know the answer
but
a lot of times
you'll people will do something for you
and then they'll ask for something in
return
it doesn't seem like any of the people
you mentioned did that everybody maybe
they did i don't know not one of them
not one of them
not one of them you know what they
wanted from me for me to do something
with my life
that's what they all those people that
fed me and took me to rides and george
you know george i hadn't seen george in
sophomore year in high school i would
communicate with him from time to time
one day in
1985. so this is hitting me man
one day in 1985
in 1984 of 85 i bought george
and he tells me that uh
that you know he's doing this and this i
got arrested that day i called george up
he bails me out he brings me to his
house
that was the beginning of my life that
was the first time i didn't i didn't get
in trouble for three months i really
gave it a chance
you know this was a kid who brought me
into his [ __ ] home how many people
bring into their home and after that
like we were talking the night on the
way to new york in front of his new
girlfriend and we were talking about
aspen like when he came to visit me and
then he came to boulder and then he came
back for the [ __ ] sentencing and
these are my friends of 30 [ __ ] years
that have been there for me and you know
when they come to the shows and awesome
they they people say my name and the
room erupts
it's got to do something for them if
they're in the room this is the same kid
i fed
and gave two dollars for the bus for and
look at these people from the podcast
coming out and applauding it's a [ __ ]
great feeling in front of my friends do
you like your friends coming or do you
prefer they didn't certain ones okay
i don't mind if they come certain ones i
could [ __ ] just go off in front of
them certain ones me knowing they're in
the room driving me crazy
because i know why they're there for are
you is it you being self-conscious or
you think they're gonna ruin it no no
then i don't ever want anything timmy
came to both shows no no no no no him
i'm saying the ones you don't want there
don't i don't know i just don't want the
ones that are going to reminisce and
breathe on my neck and to be doing
[ __ ] blow and you know they don't
want to give me a chance with the people
with the podcast people right they want
to take over the stage over the podcast
people stand right there i can't deal
with that [ __ ]
it's uh
it's interesting talking about like a
change and all that because you asked me
a few months ago like
if i could be doing anything what would
i be doing i said doing this and then
we've been talking recently about what
i'm gonna do next
and an issue i had for my whole life was
looking like looking forward like not
enjoying and i've been i was thinking
that i was i got a little bit too high
the other night
and i was just like
i don't know if i want to be a manager
like i don't know i don't this is the
first time
kind of in my life that i don't know
what i want okay let me ask you this let
me ask you this
nobody's saying manager let me ask you
this what if
what if netflix gets into the podcast
business
and they want to hire you for chief
operations of network control because
you know about podcasts
this is leading to something yeah i
don't know what it is
i don't know what it is and that you
said because i
i don't know it was to terrify me but it
listen the worst thing a man could do is
think
yeah
okay the worst thing this was something
that was told to me by a wise man when i
was 19 years old and i was bleeding when
i'm out of my [ __ ]
the worst thing a man could do is think
the only thing a man is expected to do
is get up every morning and do the best
he can and move a little closer
to reaching his [ __ ] utopia
and that's mentally spiritually
and physically that's what you go for i
did not know that at 21 guys i did not
know that i did not know that this is
the mission
to be
happy
that's it that's the mission to be
[ __ ] happy
to have the ability to go you know what
i'm not flipping burgers and they're not
burgers dog i'm not doing that this is
what i'm doing
and to have the brain to know that this
is what's not gonna make you happy and
to take chances
there's just so many things that are
part of a young man's [ __ ] life one
of the worst things are
thinking
i want you to write your goals
you know i want you to have a clear
vision of a 90-day what am i going to do
but you don't know where this is going
to end up lee
you're going to be when i'm dead and
[ __ ] buried one day you're going to
look out a window and spark up a cigar
or a joint and you're going to go look
at what i'm doing today or it all
started in a [ __ ] room
a dumb room with a nazi [ __ ] flag and
charles bronson sitting across from some
fat ex-felon that didn't know dick about
dick
because you're on the ground floor of
something huge
this is communications
and this is something that's needed
daily entertainment and communication
yeah and and
and that's it's great for me but i've
i've been talking with so many people
now like this this one and i'm gonna
respond to his email tomorrow he
he's not sure if you should go to
college for podcasting
and it's would you go to [ __ ] college
football i don't know what it's home no
no no it's the scholar this is the
college
this is the college but what's the car
who's going to teach a podcasting class
let me ask you what [ __ ] person is
going to teach a [ __ ] podcasting
class that hasn't had a podcast for five
years i would only take 10 people's
podcasting classes right now if they
taught them nothing else at a college
degree level
10 people's podcasting classes adam
carolla what makes a successful [ __ ]
podcast i wouldn't take my podcast class
i'm not a successful [ __ ] podcast but
there are podcasts out there that are
[ __ ] successful do you think they
went to college you [ __ ] [ __ ] this
is what the problem is you could go for
like sound engineering [ __ ] sound engine
this is how you learn sound engineering
by people hitting your emails and going
joey i can't [ __ ] hear you talk to
lee we figure it the [ __ ] out
because they teach you that theory but
they're not going to teach you what the
[ __ ] we learned in five years which is
still what they're going to need to do
right so no matter how much [ __ ]
chalkboards and clapping or [ __ ]
erasers you do the only way to get this
is technicality you know there's a class
in [ __ ] hollywood that you don't roll
they just teach you submissions
you do not row
it's for people who do not want that
that physical contact i learned how to
do an arm bar i do not [ __ ] row
that's great for theory
that's great for theory right but the
only way to get better at that is to
roll around and have people get on top
and twist your [ __ ] fingers and poke
you in the [ __ ] eye and
the only way to learn this the only way
to learn anything in life is to [ __ ]
do it if you want to do it while you're
getting a little theory but lee again
who's teaching these podcast class right
who let me see who who i've been i've
been a consultant i'm talking you ain't
[ __ ]
because you didn't do this day in and
day out you weren't with us at 6am in
the [ __ ] morning in a [ __ ]
apartment smoking and yelling with
[ __ ] foreigners throwing [ __ ] at you
you weren't there so this is what i'm
saying right now
this
if i was to take a podcasting class in
10 years
yeah because by that time catches morris
could teach a [ __ ] class right yeah
who knows more about when cassius gets
to his freshman year in college
and he takes a podcasting class
he's going to get up after three days
and go you're all a bunch of [ __ ]
[ __ ] it won't even take three days i
don't think won't even take the day but
that's the thing it's like
from the from the minute i can remember
even as kids you're asking what do you
want to be when you grow up and all that
and how much will you write and all you
dumb [ __ ] that are funny
wouldn't it be a book and buy a man how
many years ready to climb a [ __ ]
ladder today none of you you don't even
know what the [ __ ] you want to do when
you're 18 and you're going to fight
exactly it is the it is the worst
[ __ ] decision we make in our [ __ ]
lives because we do 50 of it for our
parents more than that four yeah
i'm just going with 50 lee i'm just
going with 50. yeah people go to college
50 percent for the parents
30 percent or 20 percent of what
surrounds them like
i want to be an underwater biologist
because a bunch of jerk balls in some
class this is college this is usc this
is san diego state now now you're going
out there the beach you have all these
things to throw your mind off you're not
in high school no more mommy's not
flipping your burgers and making your
laundry this all kicks into your day so
that underwater biology [ __ ]
becomes [ __ ] sociology 101 you know
what i'm saying psychology three
whatever the [ __ ] you choose you don't
have come on no come on they want you to
make a life decision
at 18 years old to what you want to do
and it's not even a life decision it's a
[ __ ] life decision but it is are you
paying are you paying [ __ ] money
right now for school but that's but
that's my point yes it's a life decision
that cost you a hundred thousand dollars
you got that right so you [ __ ] think
about it there's a child it's not like
okay
listen come on who the [ __ ] are you guys
getting as a child 18 you're a [ __ ]
child i was a child of 18 yeah i thought
i was the mafia and i thought i could do
this and that but i had the mind
of a [ __ ] child
and yes there's some of us that are very
special they know what they're going to
do at 18 or whatever but those
[ __ ] put a gun to their head at
38. i thought i did
i thought i knew no we ought
every child every 18 year old child
thinks they know what the [ __ ] they want
to do at 18. and they don't have a
[ __ ] idea so you know what worst case
scenario you go to school for four years
and you take a major that could turn
into anything else like a masters or
maybe law school or maybe an uh whatever
the other thing that they call it that's
the only thing i would decide what would
i do with mercy if i was 50 or 40 right
now and i would be there for mercy
you want me to tell her what i tell her
to do
honest yeah at 18.
of course i'll tell you how this
something like that for one year
i would make a child go into the
workforce labor for one year
in something that they kind of like you
know what i'm saying like something big
you can always get an internship
yeah but i want you to make money i
don't want you to be [ __ ] interning
[ __ ] you working for free
[ __ ] that i need for you to get up in
the morning and know what it is to get
230
and know how to break it up i live with
mom and dad i'm going to chip in 50. i'm
going to put 30 towards my car 25
towards my car insurance 50 throws wifi
reefer i want you to budget interning
i'm i still got to give you guitars
you got to learn how money moves when
you're a child you definitely you have
to learn how money moves when you're a
child you have to learn to put money
away when you're a child something i did
not do you have to learn to you know
there's so many things you know there's
no paper routes today i blame so much on
not having paper routes because it
teaches you how to protect your [ __ ] to
how to collect to how to sell
to how to upsell you only get sundays
for an extra 12 [ __ ] cents i'll give
you the whole week okay you learn all
these things from selling a [ __ ]
newspaper
yeah from selling a [ __ ] newspaper
because nothing teaches you more about
life than belly to belly sales
belly to belly sales so do you think
like a year of that first because i
don't like that i'm bad at that i'm bad
at selling but what i am good at like
what i think did help me was working uh
retail or customer service and then like
i don't know the gnc yeah i don't care
if you go to gnc and learn about
vitamins for a year and then you go to
yourself you know what man i thought i
wanted to be an astrologer
now i want to get into [ __ ] uh sports
medicine i want to help people do
[ __ ] sit-ups i want to help fat
people lose weight whatever the [ __ ] it
but i don't think you really know
what you're doing at 18. i gotta tell
you an interesting story before i forget
okay i tell people this all the time i
go to jiu jitsu on mondays
i go to wednesdays on higgins and i drop
it on bjj.com
people think i i'm [ __ ] uh you know
andre galvao so everybody always invites
me to their places and 90 of the times i
got to tell you something i'm [ __ ]
petrified
i'm [ __ ] petrified not because
i'm miss petrified i'm out of my comfort
zone once you're out of your comfort and
i talk about this all the time so my
plan for the last two weeks was to go to
marcelo garcia's 11 30 to 12 30
fundamental two class that was the
[ __ ] plan
i go to nope and anthony now i find out
the night before at the popes in town
they're gonna lock up all these [ __ ]
streets blah blah blah
opie and anthony ends like a [ __ ] 10
35 10 40 after the hugs and the pictures
and the whole thing i didn't hit [ __ ]
downstairs till 11 o'clock
i was [ __ ] starving i stopped i got a
severed hot dog
and then i went to hail the cab it was
20 minutes to get a cab i go [ __ ] i'm
never going to make it to myself i even
asked the guy the guy goes i got to go
the long route you won't be there till
about 12. i said [ __ ] it
let me just uh give me a ride to the a
train so i took the a train i went up
and i walked around and i had my g and
[ __ ] and i
went back and i stopped on the jersey
side at this uh
at this kettlebell place this uh
whatever crossfit place and i had
kettlebells and i
went up to account and i said listen how
much to do the kettlebells and it was 25
bucks i go okay here we go but you got
to be back by 4 30. it was like 2 15 2
o'clock for a class or just a train
train because at 4 30 the classes start
from 7 to 9 and they're like crossfit
and
uh pulling yourself up trx and all that
[ __ ] so
i saw a ufc gym in fact my nephew uh
dede's nephew uh carlos his son worked
over there when it first opened so i
went over there
and i go how much are you guys charging
i go you can buy a three day pass but
you know what just come work out bro
we'll work straight here
and i go do you have a beach uh jiu
jitsu classic we have a no gear at seven
but we have a gear at 5 30. oh my god
like okay i'll be here as i'm walking
away i go what the [ __ ] did i just say
you know
i was [ __ ] my pants lee you know
funny because 7 30 you could have been
like oh i might be late for my show but
five o'clock was right there i went
and uh
i went home and i wrote and i spoke to
some people and i thought about it and i
walked over that five i got a protein
drink and
i took my little energy pill and i
walked over there lee
the first 10 minutes were hal he made
this run i had to run in front of all
these young kids you said it's on like
the third floor too right he's on the
third floor which gives me [ __ ]
anxiety as it is but when i walk in i
saw the guy from naughty by nature track
his kids go there oh cool a lot of
celebrities a lot of football players
and basketball players live in edgewater
and fort lee and all that so i
go upstairs and i walk in this three
guys like oh perfect this will be a
small class oh [ __ ]
about five twenty eight eight kids walk
in and one guy's like joey oh my god
listen to the podcast
i ran i did a couple hip escapes i
almost had a heart attack no i didn't
even do that i didn't get to the hip
escapes i was out of breath from just
running and doing something else he was
making us do and then he made us do
uh getting out your guard 50
oh my god
i was so petrified
but i gotta tell you something lee
everybody in there
was the nicest person in the world
everyone's always nice
the [ __ ] teacher
his name is karuma anderson caroma
santos
was so [ __ ] good
he was so good i left there i was
drenched i mean my knee pads under my
knee were wet
i rolled and rolled and rolled and they
taught me how to half guard in a deep
half and i had such a good time i didn't
i i go can i give you anything he goes
no no it's on me thank you for coming i
went right downstairs and i booked a
private i came back the next day at two
o'clock
so today is the thing that i hated the
most that i i was petrified of i [ __ ]
went and did and i gotta tell you
something we had a [ __ ] great time
i had a great and now every time i go
into that area you know what i'm gonna
go see this [ __ ] anderson kuruma guy
because he was that [ __ ] good he
taught me some [ __ ] tremendous [ __ ]
not to mention i was drenched
i love when i'm workout and i'm drenched
there's one thing for your t-shirt to be
wet there's one thing from the top of
your pants to be wet there's nothing
when your knee pads and your underwear
away you're like god damn well thank you
for that light ghee by the way that
saved me the other day
oh my god but oh the santa bolt yeah oh
that's it yeah those are the hegemon oh
my god those are good they're really
ultra lightweight man ultra [ __ ]
light in the summers
there's a gear i have that's like a
[ __ ] like a like a [ __ ] a fur i
think that's what you gave me too the
first one oh my god oh yeah that's a
normal one that's heavy as [ __ ] yeah but
do you do you like going to see
different teachers because i was here
did you see people talking about that
like that they go here in a day go here
and i'm like that's a lot of money to be
spending on jiu jitsu but there must be
a benefit to it you know john evan gives
me a flat
which is very cheap because i was with
him before so he goes just pay me what
you were paying me before
vmac gives me an individual rate 15 20
bucks
for but john bud he's worth every
[ __ ] dollar and just for the school
man they're a neighborhood school so if
i go in there for i spend 200 a month on
jiu jitsu it's a lot and i don't give a
[ __ ]
it's i threw away thousands a month on
cocaine thousands
i'm spending 200 i'm something i love
doing we give the other guy 20 bucks 15
bucks for the kettlebells yeah that's
cool what do i give a [ __ ] yeah it's
worth every penny it's not like i go out
to dinners when i go to [ __ ]
premieres right i don't play like up to
rides but there's kids who like aren't
making a lot of money doing this too and
it's just it's crazy they are or they
aren't they aren't that like no there's
their money in jiu jitsu but you have to
contribute and you have to help and you
go to these schools and listen these
schools are your community
i started at vmac
when the schedule didn't suit my needs
and i had to go elsewhere it hurt my
feelings too
then i got the knee surgery i just i
love john bud and marcelo and i love
john evan over there and i love [ __ ]
hassan and my buddy zack i love all
those guys with all my [ __ ] heart man
but
egan was down in belly hills by
hollywood where i had to go i had a
relationship with him from before that's
where i went i don't like going over the
hill for jiu jitsu i like keeping in my
neighbor i'm a neighborhood [ __ ] guy
you support the things in your
neighborhood oh no but i'm saying like
when do you like going to john bud for
one thing and then he inferno is it kind
of cool seeing how different people
teach you know what man for me it's
great that i'm just involved yeah and
once my schedule adapts and and vmac
adds day classes on mondays and
wednesdays i'll just go to vmac happier
than [ __ ]
vmac is a school that's coming up
they they try it's that neighborhood
school they charge you 70 bucks a month
yeah 70 bucks a month for jiu jitsu
you know that's an and they do barbecues
and they get together they just all went
to a wedding this week and they do
little things man and that's what part
of this is when i was doing coke yeah
people call you up and you want to party
but besides that people never hit me up
and go hey man you want to go exercise
today or you want to go uh do kickboxing
[ __ ] jiu jitsu everywhere i go
somebody sends me an email and says hey
man you're a big guy like me i'm a black
belt you want me to teach you some big
guy stuff what the [ __ ] is that i'm not
a [ __ ] nose no special person for
them to reach open up that's jiu jitsu
that's why i break your balls about it
because it's a different community it's
a different feel it's what i've been
yearning
for 30 years is what i've been looking
for i didn't find it with comics
i didn't find it with comments because
50 of them are there to be your friend
and the other 50 are hoping you slip on
a [ __ ] banana peel and die
so there's no camaraderie there for me
there never really was
but if you're in this area man i had a
great time with kimura and the guy the
brian garcia guy that runs the ufc gym
he [ __ ] opened up his heart you know
listen everybody's always talking about
how they're heavy they're sick this and
that the answer's right in front of you
these people are not there to hurt you
at these gyms some of them are scumbags
but some people are genuinely there to
go hey man if you want to help me help
you lose weight i can help you what's
the matter lee
what what the [ __ ] you sitting there
blinking like a fan
this is hitting me it's not [ __ ]
hitting you i don't see no devils no
stars yet
you're gonna put some [ __ ] music on
are you gonna sit there it's [ __ ]
monday morning [ __ ] get your [ __ ]
together but the whole thing is i got
out of my comfort zone and i feel
[ __ ] great about i really do i had a
this was a one of the best weekends ever
i got to see my friends
i went to rudy's twice i had some
[ __ ] uh muscles marinara i had oh my
god the calamari was off the [ __ ]
chain
there you go no raviolis no i don't go
to [ __ ] new york themed raviolis [ __ ]
outta here
oh my god we got a live one tonight
i gotta get up and i'll tell you if i'm
high hold on
leave it up
how come you're always that [ __ ] that
bumps into the [ __ ] dj booth
you're always that [ __ ] [ __ ]
the dj booth is the entire operation you
always hit the [ __ ] thing with your
finger why is your finger even close to
the because it changes the camera too
because you leave don't worry about
changing the [ __ ] camera just leave
the music the music is the most
important thing i don't care about the
[ __ ] camera
that doesn't matter what you [ __ ] sucker
i won't stop all right you why
my i won't stop watering i know what's
wrong with your eyeballs you think you
got that thing on your left eye again
you got that fungus in your eye again
yes you do it's fine go look in the
mirrors
holy [ __ ] what this is fun yeah it's fun
what i've been telling you for years
there's nothing wrong with a good
headache
go home watch a couple of [ __ ]
episodes of narco go out and stab
somebody in your [ __ ]
acid [ __ ] reflux you know
oh doesn't matter what you meant
but it was great i uh i learned a lot
vegas was great the special
i don't know when you know it's just all
this it's just [ __ ] we have in here i
still got a cdi taped in dc
that's ready to release
we're just ready to fall to pieces now
the next mission is the book with gordon
that's it that's the next [ __ ]
mission i already started looking at it
when i was in [ __ ] new york
just little notes it's going to be tough
but i got to really focus on my writing
now so i'm gonna set two hours a day
just the [ __ ] right from now on
that's it now that i got this on the
book or just everything everything in
general i really have to there's days i
write a long time then one day i travel
and i won't write and that's the whole
thing you gotta work the [ __ ] same
muscle every day it's really important
so
stop looking up at the [ __ ] ceiling
leave there's nothing i bet to see you
like that [ __ ] that looks up what are
you looking up for next time
you're gonna go to philly and have the
pope touch in the head
they could hear you did you watch any of
the pope stuff i was on at the gym
and i'm i'm jewish man i understand that
it's a big deal for some people
i don't understand to well i don't
understand waiting in line for 12 hours
but who waited in line for 12 months
they were saying people in philly that's
what cnn was saying people were there
from like 6 30 to 16 people came from
all over the world i suppose all the
other states a fan i read about a family
volkswagen buzz i know he's not god but
he's like the level down from god isn't
that supposedly like
i don't know i don't [ __ ] know he's
just a grand high pool he seems cool
people seem to like him
well he's a hip that's what they say
he's hip or whatever as an old school
catholic how do you feel
i don't i can't lie to you
for me religion is something that you do
on your own
it should be it should be i like it on
my own i'll go to church
i could put a couple dollars in the
basket i'll eat the [ __ ] cookie i hit
a confession from time to time
but i think it's how you hold yourself
on a daily [ __ ] basis that's my
religion
that's my religion how you
you know hold yourself up on a [ __ ]
daily basis this time of year is always
weird because it's like the high
holidays it's the young people a lot of
jews on the flight today
a lot of them a lot of them
and i don't know man
my parents fought about it my dad was
less religious my mom was more so that
was weird and then it always creeped me
out how like
people would go there just to be seen
like just because they have to bring in
chairs
feel that also growing up that most
people were there to be seen i don't
know i don't think i was i don't think i
don't think i was eight but i remember
going in high school and being very up
it's just like
it's two days out of the year everyone's
there hold on i don't mean to interrupt
you go for it because i say this to
rogan he always
i could see that he always
do you feel that
a lot that most of the things people do
to be seen
or is it me and by myself and my [ __ ]
20-year cocaine paranoia i think you
point out the more my new ones
i think there's like stuff like that
that's like oh blood that's blatant is
kind of i think some people see but then
i think it's just based on experience
because like i'll be watching reality tv
with paula and i'll point out hey they
made her say that hey they reshot that
well just something i can see or like
the audio's weird
and she wouldn't notice because that's
she hasn't spent hours looking at that
so you've spent hours and hours looking
at people to make fun of them in a way
or to tell comedy about them so you
probably are more honed in on it
i would i would think
when i was uh
when i first went to church i couldn't
figure out what people would close their
eyes oh gosh and spin around and make
believe like the whole you know i
couldn't figure it out
and i started closing my eyes and i
realized nothing [ __ ] happened the
only one that does look cool are and i
know there's probably a better way to
say this but the black churches like the
ones where they're singing and having a
good time that seems like a fun way to
go i've been to those tremendous like uh
i had a friend that used to go oh my
gosh
listen church religion is what you
believe in your heart
how you act yourself accordingly
whatever the [ __ ] you believe in i don't
want to sit here and preach to people
what the [ __ ] god is or whatever because
everybody to everybody everybody has a
different god or maybe no god at all
i know there's something out there i
know there's a karma in my world in my
life
i know that karma has to do a lot with
things and i know that there's something
out there i was shown something early on
and i know there's something out there
whether i believe or not i know it i
feel it for me but
i don't think
i didn't like going to church every
sunday you went every sunday i went uh
for a few years every sunday and i
didn't like it either i thought that
when i got to boulder was the first time
it really disgusted me
that's the first time church
[ __ ] disgusting like they all go on
christmas or easter or something and
never ever get you know who was a good
catholic he was a very very good
catholic in my life my old in-laws
the kings yeah very good catholics ray
and lorraine very good catholics went to
church they did the stipend
you know they had the priesthood once a
week
but he cursed
he was in vietnam
you know it's just a belief that he had
and uh
i liked him i went to his church sacred
heart in boulder it's where i got
married
i didn't like
the gentiles that went
that sat in the front that were involved
with the church and there was one guy in
particular a realtor that was cheating
on his wife with this young chick his
wife was atrocious i mean i'd shoot her
i wouldn't cheat on at that point
but
he was cheating on her but he would sit
in the front and act like he was the
best christian and one day like he went
to give me like a lecture and i told him
like do me a favor go [ __ ] you son right
you got some pair of [ __ ] balls those
are the people that take me off and
that's
70 percent of religious people you think
it's that high well okay go to new york
42nd street eight in the morning when i
was a kid
50 of the clientele in the [ __ ] uh
boxes jerking off
were hasidic jews lee
yeah
running out of there with that dirty
jacket with a napkin would come on it to
go throw away or take it back to the
synagogue okay
and you know whatever the [ __ ] they do
with it you know lee uh these are these
uh i don't even know what they're saying
i don't want to embarrass anybody
these arabian prince when they come over
they got wives where did they come over
here did you hear about the one that
just happened in la i think it's either
l.a or florida i forget i don't know
where like this girl like was trying to
escape the compound and they couldn't
they called and had to have him arrested
why do you think what do you think these
japanese guys come over you think they
come out and play cards in vegas they
come home and they get 12 blondes they
suck dick for a living jack
five grand a night that's what they want
they don't want no misunderstandings
they don't want no amateurs they don't
want none of cosby's rejects they don't
want nothing
they don't want nothing they want
perfect well you know this is what they
people do for 2 000 [ __ ] years lee do
you think cosby ever give his word of
approval on like a hooker please i don't
know
i'm just like you did with the jellyfish
you gotta [ __ ] throw me off my beat
here i'm just as high as you [ __ ] sucker
no but it's it's um
i don't know and i'm not going to say
that i don't know if it's seventy
percent of the height
because i'm telling you all these
religious people that that listen
all these people that that pushed their
[ __ ] religious on you or at one time
correct you
you know uh the guy who [ __ ] sent me
the email last week that me and my wife
walked out with a bunch of women you
don't you should do comedy like cosby
cosby's a rapist [ __ ] you know
there's a majority of people that put
religion
that's their front is their religious
beliefs and [ __ ] but meanwhile their
personal lives their pieces of [ __ ]
their pieces are [ __ ] [ __ ] those are
the ones that [ __ ] torment me those
are the ones that eventually i say hey
stop stop stop stop with the ukulele my
cousin al cuella
i love doll i was family since i was a
little boy i knew the mother the
grandmother
you know is this kind of scary when you
look like i went to church with the
tambourine the pastor lord have mercy
prayers before dinner meanwhile he's
snorting coke eating pills and getting
his dick sucked at the dealership
why are you doing this to me why are you
embarrassing me with this relationship
me i tell you what my beliefs are and i
tell you what i've done
i was a thief the dudes who got the kill
next to jesus were [ __ ] thieves i'm
not blaming none of that [ __ ] i'm a deep
piece of [ __ ]
but in my whole heart the whole time i
would think about religion i wouldn't
think about it
you know what i'm saying like at night
when i was going to sleep i would think
of all the things i've done and then i
would think of religion and i get really
[ __ ] sad
today i baptize my daughter i [ __ ] go
to church on my own very loosely i do
not talk about it
i don't push it on my wife
there's a 7 30 mass i tell her i gotta
take a ride that's how special [ __ ] i
do it
i go i sit in the back i get emotional
it brings me back to my childhood i get
in my car
i go home and nobody knows i did it do
you understand i consider going this
week but i feel like a hypocrite it's a
temple
yeah you have to go lee go and get your
roots
these are your roots this is who the
[ __ ] you are i'm not then i'm the person
that i hated when i was eight who gives
a [ __ ] now go remind yourself why you
hated yourself on the way out call me
and go joey let's eat a star and [ __ ] it
right or wrong but then why not walk in
and see where you came from
why not walk in
maybe i'll give you an idea
maybe it'll make you go over there and
do it podcast that's probably where i
was most bored if i think about it sure
because i don't speak hebrew so those
hours
of sitting there just doing nothing
wishing for it to be over
just praying that's all i would pray for
is for it to be over you know what i
would do when i'd sit in church as a
child
i remember because i went to catholic
school so you had religious studies
so while i was in church
i would daydream about the lesson they
taught us and i would think about what
jesus you know whatever the [ __ ] story
they had that day about moses or the
corinthians whatever the [ __ ]
i would think about that you know
i don't know religion's weird with me i
just i don't like people pushing on me i
don't like none of that stuff you're a
religious person keep it to yourself
keep your belief to yourself and don't
talk about it let me see you live it
it's weird when people have that in
their like twitter profile they're like
god first or whatever okay let me see it
bro
and there's a picture you on a boat with
your tits out on a ship with some
[ __ ] uh
fake producer or some [ __ ]
that's the [ __ ] that bothers me man
everything else i don't care what people
do listen and bold i had a friend who
was a harry krishna
he looked down the block from me he
stunk
but the dude was solid as [ __ ]
molasses man he talked to you from the
heart and you know what was special
about him
he never said nothing about being a
harry krishna he never said nothing to
you did he wear like the robes around he
had the hairdo the [ __ ] thing he
stunk the shoes
but he was solid what are you gonna do
man people have their own choices in
life
as long as they don't invite me and push
it on me after the third time especially
if i'm high and i'm having a bad day
because you're always like
at three o'clock in the daytime your
mind's always on fire you're thinking
about the end of your day what's going
to happen tomorrow you're scheduling
blah blah blah blah blah blah and all of
a sudden i bump into a joke there was a
jehovah witness that was coming to north
hollywood
i had this guy strung out for maybe four
or five months do you think i was there
when i when he came a couple times i
told you i had him on the string i
talked to him for two minutes and the
phone would ring hold on let me let me
call you back listen i gotta catch you
next week and i leave i had him on a
string because he spoke to me correctly
it's when he showed up with a partner
but it pissed me off two times he showed
up solar and i spoke to him about
whatever we just kept it on a [ __ ]
very natural basis
films his religion how long he had done
it for
why he did it that he was a catholic or
whatever the [ __ ] he was and then
something always happened
but once he showed up with the partner
to shake me down
that's when the relationship ended once
they show up with two or three across
the line yeah they crossed the [ __ ]
line you want to show up [ __ ] solo
and talk to me about [ __ ] jehovah
what is it to the ambush
what are you doing you trying to crack
funnies
let me give some shout outs here
i want to give a shout out to all my
buddies i want to give a shout out to my
brother timmy holloway it's weird we
were in new york last week and it was
the anniversary of us uh doing our thing
when we were kids
and i'm proud of you and you look good i
also want to give a shout out to k job
my man in vegas who hooked us up oh yeah
bad [ __ ] [ __ ]
i had put the note in my pocket and i
forgot it and i found it on my desk so
i'm sorry it's late but i love you david
christians dabbing your [ __ ] sucker
trying to ask me if i just woke up my
man
the greatest blind comedian working
angel adorno out there and his beautiful
wife
the chinese dragons in new york who
showed up i love you little chinese
[ __ ] renee and kashion with his
band of [ __ ] hooligans and the dude
who was getting married my main man the
guy who showed up with the blizzard of
oz album i looked at that album and
almost [ __ ] broke down into tears
even tonight harry sakiri my main man in
uh glendale the flying armenian
dustin zawacki john fentros always with
us
joe scarberra
and again i want to thank bruce garcia
at the ufc gym at edgewater and my main
man anderson karuma santos
for taking good care of me and my man
levpolikev.com he's a level
at twitter if you want to hit him up and
follow him the guy does some great
[ __ ] artwork you know what i'm saying
so that's at least i had it was a
two-hearted it was i was only home two
out of ten [ __ ] days
and i did it i couldn't believe i
thought i was gonna have a nervous
breakdown along the way oh you were
talking to me about friday night okay
guys listen i get [ __ ] bored the new
york show started 11
45 again
11
45. that must be torture for me i pulled
up at 11 45 there was still a line
outside
they don't even start seating till 10 to
12 and the show starts like at 10 after
12.
it's a real new york city show i work
for that [ __ ] dollar on that show
what the [ __ ] am i
doing yeah [ __ ] so you probably get on
to close to one
i can't hold that you know me
my [ __ ] nine o'clock i gotta pop a
star i gotta get the blood going you're
really human things are happening i
popped like two stars
get the blood going from there i said
[ __ ] let me get the blood going i popped
two more i leave the house with a total
of three stars i heard already pop five
my brother picked me up at ten i popped
two stars and then in the car i popped
two more [ __ ] stars now i'm 10
minutes away from going up on stage for
the first show in new york city friday
night
i go in my pocket the phone's ringing i
go and i go what's this lump in my
pocket and it's a piece of paper with a
star that's starting to melt i i'm not
doing it i'm not gonna let a [ __ ]
good thc star melt so i popped this
[ __ ] on stage like the church
soldier you are it's new york city when
you go on stage in new york city you
gotta go up there and [ __ ] throw
[ __ ] kazams at him i went out there
friday like a [ __ ] devil
12 14 16 minutes in
lee
i feel like i am about to pass out
i get nauseated my stomach just drops to
a certain level of nausea
i can feel the temperature in my body
changing
but the heat rising in my head oh my god
sweats coming from parts of my body that
haven't had sweat on it in years at that
night part of the night it's just like
weird like i'm doing jiu jitsu sweating
on stage all of a sudden i'm looking to
my left
on this side of stage [ __ ] packed
house
and all of a sudden my vision goes
oh no
in the back of my mind i'm like i'm
about to pass
i really want lee no [ __ ] and they knew
it the audience knew see were you still
talking still talking but kind of
incoherently
and all of a sudden i bruised
and i just went into a bit or something
and it saved me and i felt myself work
and i kept breathing i kept saying joe
just breathe
and i kept going through it and then
after about six minutes i told the
audience what happened and they caught
it
they started laughing they saw the sweat
on my body it was [ __ ] amazing i
[ __ ] loved it lee
oh i love that does that make you want
to do animals before you go on stage no
no i'm not doing it [ __ ] no more
until tuesday yeah before the laugh
or tuesday no i uh i don't know like i
don't i'm out of stars
and you know we've eaten a [ __ ] 2 000
stars in two weeks like it's over we got
to give the stars a break i'm
embarrassed to even hit the guy up
anymore my main man he hit me up today
saying hello and stuff like that but i'm
embarrassed to even [ __ ] uh
why are you laughing later how you
feeling [ __ ]
huh you're feeling good right
yeah i don't think it's really listen
let me tell you the story i'm at the
[ __ ] stand i'm minding my own
business
guy comes in joey he was there last year
gives me a hug i love this kid i love
him everything about him i don't know
what his name is and it doesn't really
[ __ ] matter and also i don't know
where he goes i got acid oh no i go
[ __ ] let's see what you got he had a
whole sheet with einstein on it
that was a piece of einstein's head you
had what part like the hair over here
over to the [ __ ] oh it's good maybe
i'll grow hair and then yeah cool so he
[ __ ] he gave me two pieces as soon as
he was gonna as soon as he was giving it
to me because
make sure one of them is philly
that's how much people love you so i
said now i was in my kitchen at the
hotel and the pieces of paper fell out
on the floor and i caught it because
they could [ __ ] disappear and i got
it and i put it under my jersey mike's
point guard where it was nice and tight
and i put a piece of tissue in there so
it couldn't [ __ ] fall out
and boom there we are
here we are a little acid though for us
but you know what it's not the acid that
i used to get as a kid we dropped it at
nine something
it's 10 26 i'm not seeing nothing but we
haven't played any music yet what do you
want to play let's play some [ __ ]
music just to get this [ __ ] party
started
i didn't bring my vapor pen but we got a
[ __ ] we got a jar that gorilla
biscuit oh gee whatever you want to
smoke more on top of this this is what
you count this is how you fire the fire
yeah
oh my god this is how you fire the fire
what we're gonna do is we're gonna do
the pot we're gonna
put a song on something to trip to you
wanna put something heavy on [ __ ] it
something really heavy
extra heavy
deep deep deep heavy how deep
all right let's play sabbath bloody
sabbath
just for the [ __ ] lyrics and then
we'll blast into some uh this sabbath
bloody sabbath maybe some [ __ ] brain
salad surgery by emerson lake and palmer
or something like that i don't [ __ ]
know lately
they didn't take it down that thing
lives on this side well i'll find it
somewhere else it's just the one we had
saved
watch the beginning of this it's [ __ ]
the guitar is tremendous
oh no don't do it
that's how you do it [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] i hope you're with me
[ __ ]
monday morning
september 28th october is coming who the
[ __ ] do you think you're dealing with
it's the church [ __ ] edibles acido a
[ __ ] number and 10 days of [ __ ]
vegas in new york city and i'm still
taking
[ __ ] it
grab your balls it's gonna be a
beautiful [ __ ] week
what
turn that [ __ ] off
we're [ __ ] for youtube
listen man
it was a great [ __ ] week that's all i
want to say and i got the reason why i'm
doing this i i really uh
we're lucky
we're [ __ ] lucky man when i was up on
148th street walking around
and i walked up that hill i can't tell
you how lucky we are that we have each
other and that we're growing every day
we grow together on the show and we see
different things and hey people come and
people go i get it man i don't give a
[ __ ] as long as you got something and
you [ __ ]
but this weekend i really learned about
friendship again i uh
i never forget about it i always keep it
dear to my [ __ ] heart because i saw
the gift of it as a child and it
blossomed
and uh
just sitting across from timmy and
talking to him and sitting across from
lubes this week
and uh going to dinner with venery and
james and
just seeing my friends
i don't know it makes me uh
validated i don't know it just really
makes you
value the gift of friendship man you
have a friend
you know everybody always says i don't
have enough friends i just got an email
a few weeks ago a guy said he was shy
and he has friends but he doesn't know
how then i go you know what
to have good friends you got to be a
good friend that's it that's the bottom
[ __ ] line
you know you want a guy to like you you
want to build a bond with somebody you
got to pick up the [ __ ] phone you got
to buy them to do [ __ ]
and that's how you build bonds you know
anybody could uh
build the [ __ ]
be fake friends
you know i hate this hollywood fake
friendship
it's scary to invite like i'm i'm a shy
person too
i don't have many friends outside of
this thing i invite somebody to yeah
that's
it's i i guess it's hard to say that we
meet people
we meet different people
you meet 10 people
if you're normal
you're gonna like three of them correct
maybe i mean three people you know like
right maybe you have the same uh
not the same uh yeah interest
yeah you have the same [ __ ] interest
whatever the [ __ ] it is
you pursue it you keep in touch with
them
you let them know you have their back
for those kids that came to get me at
the hotel and whatever let me tell you
something
i know that i could ask them for
anything i don't want nothing from them
but that's 30 years they're not around
because they're fake friends or
they're like hi we knew each other in
the eighth grade oh my god my son loves
you now [ __ ] that they've been there
since day one they fed me
when there was nothing there there was
no reason to feed me
there was no reason for them to [ __ ]
invite me to the house i was just a
[ __ ] dirty kid from the neighborhood
that was a thief
but somewhere in there [ __ ] somewhere
in their soul
they [ __ ] gave me a chance
they gave me a chance bro and a lot of
people didn't
so i'm really happy to have that and if
you have that in your life those certain
people maybe you're off the track with
them pick up the [ __ ] phone and
that's it because like i've said a
thousand times all you need is three
people in your life see what happened
was that show friends [ __ ] every young
man up after that everybody wants to
hang out with eight people oh my god and
have parties and go on vacation [ __ ]
that noise
three [ __ ] somebody gets killed
nobody knows nothing
all those movies right when they go on
bachelor parties these guys they kill
the stripper now you got to worry about
eight people
it's a joke but what i'm saying is in
reality man the gift of friendship is
[ __ ] beautiful
i'm very fortunate to uh
they're really seeing it from the inside
out a lot of people never get to get the
friendship from the inside out so
what do you think [ __ ] though
i think it's pretty cool i don't have
any smoke another joint
no really why are we smoking our number
to set this mother separate pigeons
loose i don't know how i'm going home
you know how you're getting home you're
fine oh man wait 50 milligrams 200
milligrams oh [ __ ] stop it
stop it it's always this it's always
that the rappers are right there
gentlemen ladies and gentlemen of the
court
what are you looking for nothing i ain't
looking for dick every time i ask you
you sit there like i'm a mama i'm gonna
be in toledo ohio
at the funny bone but listen anyway
let's start from scratch here
this weekend when i went down to uh
to new york
i actually missed the hemp protein the
onion chocolate hemp protein i got the
recipe down so good now
with the ice cubes how many ice cubes
with the water with the banana
that is the best [ __ ] i and i've had
other proteins other companies say hey
try our protein i've tried it i like the
chocolate flavor
on it has the best [ __ ] hemp cocoa
[ __ ] protein you'll ever taste and
they say the hemp is better for you and
your stomach i don't know about this i
just know i never get clogged up none of
that stuff on it has some great [ __ ]
products they really do today i took the
shroom tech
and i also took the one uh the thing
before i got on the plane i only got one
package left because it's a six hour
[ __ ] flight i didn't sleep last night
what's it called turn around 180 right i
put that right in the water as soon as
they came ladies like what do you wanna
mimosa no give me [ __ ] water [ __ ]
she gave me a little container water i
put it right in there shook that
[ __ ] i drank that i had already
two stars of me i don't have time for
cheddar chatter i popped that whole
[ __ ] gallon a little eight 16 ounce
water with the 180. listen guys i had my
little breakfast i went to sleep for
three hours to sleep out in your mess i
only took an hour and a half nap today
i'm here with you guys that's i don't
know you see how i'm so jet lagged that
[ __ ] that's for [ __ ] [ __ ] six
hours there six hours back i didn't
sleep the night before save it for
somebody else that's the power of
[ __ ] on it the proof is in the
footing look at my [ __ ] eyes and i
came up and played with the [ __ ] two
and a half year old so don't [ __ ]
tell me go to honor.com whether it's the
shroom tech sport the turnaround 180 the
alpha brain which is basically the
[ __ ] turtle or 180 with just
different stuff in it that's all this is
alpha brain even helps when you fly
against jet lag not that i'm one of
those guys that's gonna sit there and
cry i'm just like no i'm not one of
those [ __ ] fruitcakes do me a favor
go to honor.com right now and press in
church and get 10 off on your first
order if you fly a lot honor is the way
to [ __ ] go even if you just want to
lift weights or whatever whatever you
want to do walk around the neighborhood
on a protein part of the hemp protein as
good as it gets that shroom tech when i
fly look at me i'm not sick people fly
they get sick the shroom tech uh not the
immune again there you have it people so
the proof is in the pudding i don't give
a [ __ ] what you think for you guys at a
single
you know
you go home at night you gotta eat fast
food you don't know what the hell to eat
i got an idea for you how about some
blue apron
blue apron's got some delicious
nutritious meals but the best thing is
it's gourmet recipes and all fresh
ingredients all you need to do is make
them and they get delivered right to
your door blue apron let me tell you
what they got this week for the
two-person plant i don't care how lonely
you are you could always find some
[ __ ] mook to come over and eat
they got the pan seared uh
steaks and the cajun catfish are you
[ __ ] kidding me or not oh are you
kidding me or what gets delivered right
to your door all you gotta do is take it
out of the box put out your frying pan
your baking pan whatever it calls for
put they even send you the seasonings
you do everything they do everything all
you gotta do is put it together they
tell you 4 25 for 16 and a half minutes
they tell you everything a [ __ ] momo
can figure this out okay so what you do
is that's for the two-person plan let's
say you got a family of four let me tell
you what they got they got shepherd's
pie they got chicken chicken pressed
tartars
that i mean come on who can live with
these things because i don't know how to
make a chicken toilet nice and fresh
with different cheeses they always got
nice salad everything is always on the
healthy side the calories i mean this is
500 and 700 calories between 500 and 700
calories a meal yeah they saw some bum
on there twitter to joe rogan me and
whatever the thing let me tell you
something i get these sent to me i love
them i [ __ ] love them i could name
like 10 dishes the tilapia they sent me
was delicious they sent me those tacos
dealer everything i've got from them
that i have cooked in that house has
been my wife makes the bok choys and all
that she likes that stuff when i'm out
of town so do me a favor all right i'm
doing i'm doing you a salad again as our
listeners will get two meals for free go
to blueapron.com
joey and start cooking incredible meals
at home with blueapron.com so please go
to blueapron.com look at the menus look
at the prices you're going to be blown
away but i'm going to do you one better
i'm going to give you two meals for free
right off the bat think about this pan
seared steaks delivered to your house
you're tired you don't know what the
hell you want to do 9 out of 10 you go
eat fast food or whatever it's the same
amount of money you cook it you control
your calories you get healthy do me a
favor blue apron
joey and get two meals for free on uncle
joey again nailed it life.com you got a
vapor you like smoking wax you want to
see the [ __ ] devil
go to nailgatelife.com right now and
look at the great selection of vapor
pens they got plus they do those
groupies and models but unless you live
in california you're getting dick don't
even ask dummy all right so do yourself
a favor go to nailed it life.com first
order you get on the vape pen 20 off so
it's 50 you get it for 40 delivered to
your house everything we do here i get
it delivered to your house that's the
beauty of blue apron it gets delivered
to your house the vapor pen delivered to
your house on it delivered to your house
you just go with joey diaz to get the
vapor pen
use what code word joey dears to use the
vape and also a lot of people complain
about the bottles
and when i put the nasal spray in my
nose do me a favor go listen to somebody
else
i'm not [ __ ] around with you people i
come up here on a sunday night away from
my family oh well can you please use a
different form of container you're
making too much garbage
how about when they come in your mouth
what do you do with that
please you some of you [ __ ]
listen to the wrong uh and
i'm over it like we have we have a
[ __ ] family here if a little water
bottle insults you maybe you're hanging
out with the wrong people maybe go to
starbucks and get your little hat with
the umbrella whatever the [ __ ] you do
all right
how you feeling lisa yeah see i'm
feeling pretty great society makes
a big deal smiling about nothing lee lee
this is what i've been trying to talk to
you for 20 years when i was a kid they
tried to scare the [ __ ] out of me i live
in fear lee oh i live in fear i was
scared to go into a [ __ ] jiu jitsu
gym i almost ran away i live in fear
don't be scared of nothing in your life
give it a [ __ ] shot who gives a [ __ ]
who gives a [ __ ] what you're not going
to die
you think i'm do you think my buddy
would give us something that's going to
make us dies and make yourselves give
you a little smile on your face listen
this ain't the acid i used to get an 80
[ __ ] 1 or 78 or whatever when you're
high for 12 hours like we'd already be
off our rockers we'd be hearing noises
and [ __ ]
thank god that's not happening and we
put uh 10 milligrams of tea 200
milligrams that's not 200 you know i
never give you 200. you do you eat more
than 200 on a regular basis [ __ ]
years cut it out [ __ ] we got to
we're back tomorrow night eight o'clock
with my main man
mickey slicky bettencourt and then we're
back wednesday afternoon with the church
of what's happening now again thank you
people who came out to vegas to support
the special
and thanks to all the [ __ ] who
came out this weekend uh
this is becoming something great man i
love you guys you guys are making me a
[ __ ] better person so thank you
for helping me man all right like i said
you got people in your life that matter
go give them a [ __ ] tackle i love
those guys i really did i had a great
[ __ ] time with you you had a great
time the last like few times you went
yeah so thank you very much see you
[ __ ] tomorrow night monday
morning you'll be listening to this wake
up grab your [ __ ] ain't not for free
[ __ ] suckers
can i have the
[ __ ] come on lee put the [ __ ]
music on again you're slowing me down